for more we're joined by your grocer
he's an economist and he's the president
of the european school of management and
technology here in berlin good to have
you with us now aside from this language
barrier that was mentioned in our report
what other obstacles are there why are
highly skilled workers from abroad not
coming to germany
i think one main reason is that also
traditionally there have not been too
many skilled foreign labor participants
in the german market and this of course
brings then a certain path with it so
this means if there has been none
no one will follow and i think this is a
tradition that germany now needs to
build and how i mean how can you make
germany more attractive to these people
germany now has one great opportunity
which is that it's seen as a real
anchor of stability in the economic
crisis uh german companies have a great
reputation worldwide so therefore we
need just need to use the opportunity to
make it attractive for foreigners to
come here to accommodate them
and to actually make everything possible
that they really feel at home here well
as a matter of fact
last year migration to germany was at a
record high so obviously a lot of people
from cash-striped eurozone nations a lot
of high-skilled workers are coming to
germany but that alone can't be the
solution for our demographic problem can
it
um it is rather a short-term fix and
than a real long-term solution we need
to think about having a plan
a real plan about
how to attract
gifted individuals to germany and how to
make them feel at home here in
particular also making it possible for
them
to really increase our prosperity or
economic welfare now this incentive is
somewhat missing in the coalition
agreement the agreement has been
criticized for many other things as well
by your business colleagues as well
what's the biggest criticism that you
have if there is any
the main criticism is that there is not
much foresight in terms of fiscal
consolidation also in terms of the
retirement system so that it looks like
that too much too many promises are made
without really thinking about who's
going to pay for them
don't go away we'll be talking to you in
just